قال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سوليفان ان الاداره الامريكيه تعمل على
اعلى مستوى في سبيل التوصل لصفقه تبادل في
خصه واوضح سوليفان في حديث لشبكه اي بي سي
ان امكانيه التوصل لصفقه جديده يعود لحركه
حماس مشيرا الى ان تحقيقها ليس وشيكا حسب
قوله الرئيس بايدن يقود جهود التوصل الى
صفقه جديده وقد تحدث مع قاده قطر ومصر من
اجل التوسط لهذه الصفقه نحن على اتصال
دائم بنظرائه الاسرائيليين بهذا الشان
الهدف هو اطلاق الرهائن باقرب فرصه ممكنه
والامر يعود لمدى استعداد حماس للقبول
بذلك لا استطيع القول ان الصفقه باتت
وشيكه ولكن في نهايه المطاف هذه الانواع
من المفاوضات تبدا عاده ببطء ثم تتسارع
ولذا فانه من الصعب وضع جدول زمني دقيق
لكن الصفقه بالتاكيد ليست
وشيكه